welcome back to special report let's
take a look at the map and what's
happening in ukraine you can see the red
areas those are russian controlled or
secured areas it is increasing we have
seen more attacks in keeve and our guys
on the ground are seeing that the
increasing uh number kharkiv still
getting bombarded in some parts but
those places are not controlled by
russian forces they're trying to circle
those cities however in the south we
told you that move from crimea
going this way to maripol and this way
to karasawan karasana now in control of
russian forces according to the mayor
there also russian forces going up here
to ena hodar
the largest nuclear plant in europe
zepersia is right here and the residents
of this town
set up a blockade and actually tried to
stop russian forces from getting into
the plant itself there is fighting
around there but the russians do not
control
that area there are also
plans for more marine launches we are
told
to try to get the city of odessa so the
southern strategy for
the russians seems like
pretty significant now one of the things
we're watching is how many missiles
are being fired into ukraine uh u.s
intelligence british intelligence
estimate 480 missiles russian missile
launches since the start of this
invasion 480 total now of those 230 have
come from inside ukraine these missile
launches there are 160 fl fired from
russia into ukraine you have 70 missiles
being fired from belarus to various
targets inside and the rest coming from
ships in the black sea so
the number of missiles going into
ukraine is pretty significant one of the
things pentagon officials say is that
they have seen these launch systems for
thermabaric missiles
24 thermobaric bombs basically on one of
these launchers but they don't have
evidence that is used yet thermobaric
bombs essentially there is an explosion
and it scatters this thin cloud of uh of
chemicals and oxygen and then another
triggered explosion sets that on fire it
is really uh used for population it was
used in grozny it was used in syria it
is a devastating weapon that penetrates
shelters and buildings again no evidence
that's been used but evidence that those
launchers are in ukraine this is one of
the areas that we've been looking at
about that that convoy again 40 miles
long
it's right in this area getting
resupplied from this base in belarus
this is cherniv up in the
north northern center of ukraine and it
is a big target for ukrainian forces and
they have been taking out some of those
armored vehicles in that column
with both planes and drones this is a
satellite shot of that convoy
where it continues for 40 miles but has
been largely stalled and is probably one
of the
biggest targets you're ever going to see
in a war fighting
environment and that's one of the things
that
u.s officials say the ukrainians may be
taking
an effort to get at that vehicle those
vehicles before they encircle a city
like heave with troops now as we go out
to the west leve russian troops are
going to make deeper advances into
ukraine but citizens throughout the
country are being urged to use guerrilla
tactics against the invaders sometimes
those convoys are part of that the
russians could be sending amphibious
troops as we mentioned to the ukrainian
shores lucas tomlinson